[Music]  Europe's bees are having a rough time of  it fewer and fewer people are eating  honey counterfeit and adulterated  versions are on the rise and every year  100,000 tons of the stuff actually come  to the EU from China MEP s want to  protect the apical Chur sector by  forcing producers who adulterate their  honey  to follow a u law or risk punishment  bees are a vital part of EU agriculture  and have an impact on 76 percent of food  production in the EU but certain  pesticides used for crops are having a  harmful effect on bee populations the  European Parliament is to set up a  special committee to look into how these  pesticides are approved in particular  investigating possible conflicts of  interest Parliament also wants European  beekeepers to get more financial support  to make Europe a thriving market for  honey and other bee products hopefully  making life a little sweeter for  Europe's peas